[Música]
como avanzamos se cumple un año del
régimen de excepción de El Salvador
declarado por el presidente nayib bukele
en marzo del 2022 con apoyo del Congreso
dio la orden de efectuar arrestos
masivos para frenar la violencia después
de un fin de semana de casi 90
homicidios en 2018 la tasa de este
crimen estaba en 50,4 por cada 100.000
habitantes para este año las autoridades
prevén que estará en dos por cada
100.000 vamos al análisis con Zaira
Navas quien es especialista en seguridad
y jefa del área de Estado de derecho de
la ong gracias a esa era por estar en
directo a América y Por cuánto tiempo
más puede mantener bukele su estado de
excepción ya ha sido renovado en
múltiples ocasiones y llegamos hasta un
año
bueno Muchas gracias muy buenos días la
Constitución de la República establece
con mucha Claridad el régimen de
excepción solo puede prorrogarse por una
vez Es decir por 30 días sin embargo hoy
cumplimos un año del régimen de
excepción esto implica una flagrante
violación a la Constitución de la
República Pero además hay otros
elementos que obviamente violan la
Constitución y esto se ha convertido en
una medida de política pública
permanente que implica ya no solo que
hay un estado una situación que obliga a
que el estado adopte poderes de
emergencia y que el estado ponga un
régimen de excepción sino que esto se ha
vuelto en una medida que permanentemente
viola los derechos de la población que
tiene a miles de personas detenidas sin
proceso hay que aclarar que sesenta y
cinco mil personas que el gobierno
anuncia haber detenido ninguna de ellas
ha sido llevada a juicio todas
inmediatamente son detenidas y enviadas
a prisión hasta este momento se han
emitido reformas a la legislación penal
para que vayan a juicio hasta diciembre
de este año Bueno pero sobre eso Zaira
Quiero preguntarle cuando le decía Por
cuánto tiempo más se puede mantener el
estado de excepción pues qué es lo que
va a pasar cuando esta violencia deje de
ser tratada como una emergencia es decir
podría darse un efecto rebote o qué va a
pasar con todas estas personas que están
represadas en las cárceles como usted lo
dice sin un proceso cuando llegue el
momento de hacer un juicio o un debido
proceso penal
bueno nosotros estimamos que el
presidente bukele lo que quiere es
mantenerse en el poder y esto significa
que va a llegar el 2024 de manera
inconstitucional se va a reelegir Y
probablemente Entonces porque hay una
situación que está ocurriendo ya las
cárceles están capturadas y esto implica
que no pueden soportar y por eso la
cantidad de violaciones a derechos
humanos Gente desnutrida muriendo
etcétera una de las tantas razones Esto
va a tener un efecto rebote sin
precedente ya en este momento están
detenidas miles de personas inocentes
precisamente porque no hay un juicio ya
en este momento estamos viendo como la
condición de mucha familias ha caído en
deterioro Pero además de eso cuando
estas personas salgan personas que han
sido torturadas abusadas detenidas
injustamente etcétera
en algún momento Tienen que salir estas
personas no van a salir re socializadas
ni reeducadas como establece la
normativa penal en nuestro país o la
normativa penitenciaria por el contrario
son personas la cárcel es un ente
criminógeno es decir va a haber más
posibilidades de que estas personas
adquieran hábitos criminales en
condiciones en las que se encuentran la
verdad es que los homicidios bajaron en
el país mucho antes del régimen de
excepción y Esto fue producto de un
pacto ilícito que tuvo el gobierno con
las pandillas Pero pero sobre ese tema
tampoco es aire se ha dicho nada Es
decir hay acusaciones aquí allá de que
el gobierno tenía un pacto con las
pandillas un pacto que finalmente se
rompió
porque no hay lugar a una a una
investigación por corrupción del
gobierno porque es lo que detiene esa
vía
Bueno lo que pasa es que este gobierno
tiene el control de todas las
instituciones del estado en mayo de 2020
destituyó a la sala de en mayo de 2021
perdón destituyó a la sala de lo
constitucional
nombró un nuevo fiscal general de la
república no hay quien investigue pero
sí se ha determinado esto el
departamento de estado de Estados Unidos
ha señalado de manera muy concreta este
tema y recientemente el fiscal del este
de Nueva York ha procesado
varios miembros de la rambla nacional Es
decir de la jerarquía de esta estructura
de la Mara MS y ha mencionado con
Claridad que esto ha servido o ha sido
posible por una negociación entre el
gobierno y esta estructura criminal es
muy peligroso que vivamos en un estado
que presenta resultados a partir de una
negociación ilegal y que mantiene
detenidas a miles de personas
probablemente muchas de ellas sí son
pandilleras pero no han recibido un
debido proceso y lo más gravedad Es que
es que hay miles de personas inocentes
detenidas mire y está esta gran paradoja
entre las denuncias de organizaciones de
Derechos Humanos versus la sensación de
seguridad que empiezan a experimentar
los salvadoreños y que han hecho que
nayib bukele goce de grandísima
popularidad incluso fuera de su país
pero por qué no hay repercusiones a
pesar de las denuncias que se han hecho
decir hay alguna forma ustedes aspiran a
Que se active algún mecanismo
internacional para que se investigue y
se indague más dentro de estos estados
de emergencia que se mantienen en
renovación constante bueno el gobierno
de bukele desde su inicios y ahora mucho
más ha mantenido una campaña
publicitaria permanente a nivel nacional
e internacional e incluso apegado en su
país y en otros países esto implica que
se venda como que este es un país muy
seguro que estamos en desarrollo
etcétera es cierto hay una disminución
de homicidios pero yo como yo ya
planteaba esta disminución se produjo
desde que usted le llegó al gobierno y
es el resultado de una negociación
lingüística ahora por qué la población
salvadoreña lo percibe de manera
distinta es que es cierto incluso desde
antes de que bukele asumiera el Salvador
venía teniendo una disminución
comprensible de homicidio si lo digo en
estos términos Porque allá por 2015
teníamos veinte homicidios diarios y
bukele recibe el gobierno con nueve
punto cinco homicidios diarios sin
embargo lo que nos venden todos los días
Es que este es un país muy seguro pero
la población salvadoreña no sale de sus
casas después de las nueve diez de la
noche pero la situación de robos la
situación de extorsiones no ha
disminuido en el país pero los mensajes
publicitarios son tan fuertes que genera
esta percepción de seguridad Mire le
agradezco Lamentablemente Nos quedamos
sin tiempo especialista en seguridad de
jefa del área de Estado de derecho de la
ong cristol gracias a usted personal y
si sus apreciaciones Gracias y a
nuestros televidentes continuamos con
ustedes en directo América quédense con
nosotros
[Música]